those Dunsey almost cursed out of
practice
caught us him he didn't let it out but
we know where he was going with that
that's the first time we knew coach
Dungy can actually get mad at somebody
that's the untold story what happened
what did he almost say well we wasn't
locked in the way we should have
practiced and I won't reveal what he was
about to say but I just just know that
it wasn't a word that's normally in his
vocabulary telling stories about his
coach in Indianapolis Tony Dungy and
work done same thing Tampa Bay practice
guys weren't getting it done and coach
got a little upset and it got everyone's
attention because coach almost said
something that they never heard coach
say you know it's funny I
I remember those two incidents but I
wasn't really as the time that I
actually got mad and really blew off
some steam my first year in Tampa we had
two guys on Tuesday miss appointment
Reagan upshot was supposed to be at a
elementary school he forgot
Eric rent was supposed to be at an
autograph signing he was 45 minutes late
and that's that's when they actually
heard it you did we cannot do this and
we're not going no we're live right yeah
[Laughter]
so so it was practices where they just
the energy wasn't right things were
concentration wasn't there and I would
only say hey we got to be about winning
and some I don't know what word they
thought was coming out but it was all
about winning right all right coach
Dungy is gonna stay with us here for a
while Rodney Harrison as you may have
seen is here he doesn't want to wait his
turn he wants to come on right now but
we don't have space for him and Tony
Dungy gets priority over Rodney Harrison
so we're gonna spend some time with
coach as we get you ready for Super Bowl
54 and it is
Friday edition of pro football talk live
NBC sports radio NBC SN the little good
friends in the UK and Ireland joined the
program on Sky Sports our number two
over for our extravaganzas day hall of
fame head coach Tony Dungy coach yeah
we've had a fun week and we were talking
earlier about how both work done and
Reggie Wayne told us some stories about
their time with you but obviously
anybody who's ever encountered you has
nothing but the highest praise and they
just that there's a glow that comes over
them when they talk about their time
with you well and those are my guys too
and and that's the thing people say hey
what do you miss what did you take from
it those relationships and those guys I
remember Warrick Dunn coming in as a 21
year old and saying you know we're
talking about giving back to the
community being part of Tampa and he's I
want to do something I'm gonna do
something special I'm gonna honor my mom
and and you don't know what that's gonna
be but it ends I've been 174 houses for
single moms and John Lynch who's with
the 49ers now I want to do something too
and there's scholarships for worthy
students in the Tampa area right and
when you see guys go from hey I just
want to be on the team I just want to
start I want to win a Super Bowl - I'm
gonna do something different it's it's a
thrill it really is yeah well it's a
tribute to you coach I mean there's some
of those guys you had on those teams
they're just great people and that's
because of you and I know I witness it
every week and I probably bring down
your profile as a human being on a
weekly basis but you know what I'm
always amazed by to coach is just that
you know a great coach you're awesome
you're a communicator all that but like
the real fact of the matter of how you
the person motivated people on the team
like I know I've had coaches where I
didn't want to let my coach down and how
many times your ex teammates have said
to me like he was a guy that I was gonna
do the little things during the week and
at practice because they didn't want to
let you down they were all about that
and I just I had to say that and you
just got a magical way about you that
way you really do well thank you and
that that's what we tried to create and
it's interesting John Lynch when he went
to San Francisco we were on the phone
and he talked about creating the culture
he said we want to create a culture out
here
of winning and that's what I want to do
and I said John well you you know how to
do that get the right guys in demand
that excellent right and you're gonna be
fine and that that's what they've done
yeah they have have you had a chance to
talk to John as the superbowl approaches
I have and he's a little nervous and I
keep telling him I have a feeling and
everyone thinks it's gonna be a close
game and a great game and I hope it will
be but when the Bucks went to the
Superbowl I talked to John and I said
you guys are you're gonna blow the
Raiders out because they haven't seen a
defense like this right and John was
like oh no don't say that don't say that
but it was it was this high-powered
offense Jerry Rice Tim Brown Charlie
garner Rich Gannon there on the ball all
over the place and the Bucks came in I
think people didn't expect you're right
I remember watching the game on TV and
going whoa the Bucks look like they're
in fast-forward and the the Raiders look
like they're in slow motion and over and
I know that you know I think there is
some sentiment out there where they feel
like it's it could be a close game but I
think if everybody thinks it's gonna be
a blowout it'll be the 49ers that kind
of just overwhelm the Chiefs yeah and
you feel that way too with that it's the
front they're so big and fast and agile
and Patrick mahomes has been able to
create on everybody that he's plating
right especially in the playoffs I don't
know if he's gonna have time to create
yes game we'll see find that really is
the key and I agree with you coach
because there's this perception the
teams are so evenly matched it feels
like just one fluke here one big play
there and one team's gonna get broken
and Dan Marino was talking about that
earlier in the week because Super Bowl
19 the Dolphins of the 49ers we thought
ATS gonna be a great game down to the
wire well the Dolphins got snapped early
by the 49ers and it just all falls apart
and that's another one I picked that
game wrong we had played both teams in
84 season right and the Dolphins blew us
out twice with just Marino and just
unbelievable passing and just seemed
like they couldn't be stopped and we
beat the 49ers gave them their only loss
and we slowed Montana and those guys
down so I'm thinking this high-powered
offense they're going to outscore San
Francisco but the San Francisco defense
was underrated and and they made a
difference and they slowed the dolphins
down and kind of won the game handily so
I'm sitting there thinking what San
Francisco has a great offense Kansas
City has a great offense Kansas City has
a good defense but San Francisco has a
great defense right and I'm just
wondering why Kansas City's favored by a
couple of points when you look at anyway
it's because of this big guy that's
wearing the one-in-five jersey over here
right Superman we're back and you can't
stop right you know I'm always
interested just like take us into what
it's like being the head coach on a
Friday of the Superbowl like what were
you what were you nervous at that point
or were you just one of the game to get
here what were the feeling I stayed in
my normal routine
my boys were really young at the time
and so we went to the NFL experience off
and we did what I normally do on Fridays
take the family out and so Friday
afternoon we're at the NFL experience
and people are looking I would have been
like that looks like the head what's he
doing here no so we're having fun Friday
night we went to the gospel presentation
but all our work was done but I'll tell
you I can sympathize with Sean McVeigh
Sean said last year I think I
overthought this whole process that can
happen because you have your week at
home yeah we're an Indianapolis you put
in your game plan you do everything just
like you would a normal week and then
you come down here and you repeat it
right and you start thinking gosh I
don't want to leave anything out I want
to make sure I'm doing so you start
overthinking and I remember all week up
in Indiana we'd said we're keeping the
ball away from Devon were kicking to the
corners were practising squib kicks were
poaching it hi were punting out of
bounds he's not going to touch the ball
and I get down here during the week and
I started thinking this is a Super Bowl
we can't play scare we can't do this and
then we have a chapel service about
David and Goliath and the chaplain says
you know David ran right at Goliath he
wasn't scared that was a difference and
I said yeah we're playing scared you
know what I come in we're gonna kick the
ball I hope we lose the toss I hope we
kick it right down the middle we pound
him and they're gonna know we mean right
right set the tone
worst decision dumbest decision but that
was having a week too much to think
about this right I took it to the house
for the cold for that day in Miami that
rainy day that was the other thing too
you tell that story about Peyton Manning
the weatherman that week we are looking
at the weather reports you know two
weeks ahead of time
14 day in advance it might rain we need
to practice with wet balls in Spain I
live in Florida there's been 40 Super
Bowls it's never rained before but he
know we just need to do this if we
practice with wet balls Wow and sure
enough it rains the whole game but we
were ready for it we were prepared
because that was Payton leave no stone
unturned yeah well what was his attitude
for Super Bowl week because it was such
a big moment for both you like as far as
legacy and everything and people were
riding him so hard at that time he was
into it he wanted to play well
definitely wanted to win and he took it
to the nth degree again he watched every
game of the Bears all 16 games
he watched the three preseason or three
postseason two postseason games so he's
watched all this and then he tells Jim
sores you our backup quarterback I want
you to watch their four preseason games
to see if they did anything in the
preseason that we haven't seen I mean he
just was on and I'm like okay just relax
we know these guys you play against this
defend right every day in practice you
don't need to know Tampa to like you
right but he was dialed in Reggie told
us the story about being over to
Peyton's house at one point and he's got
a theater room and he opens the door and
he's like this looks like the meeting
remote from the facility all the way
down to every detail every single thing
it's the exact same room it was and I
didn't know you know I'm at that time I
don't know anything about Wi-Fi or and
any of that he's got the exact hook up
everything that Jim Caldwell and Tom
Moore did had practice in that meeting
room could get transferred right to his
house so he got the game plans Tuesday
night hot off the presses
he got the cut-ups everything that we
were gonna see on Wednesday pumped right
into his basement
and that's the that's the way he
prepared did you ever feel like you had
to like like like relax Peyton that he
was yeah I mean you what
we're doing that he just did you just
tell him we had a 7-year fight over
family Saturday I came from the Steelers
organization Saturday you brought your
kids to practice right it was when they
could see where their dads worked I'm
sitting there holding John Stallworth
son when it's offensive period he's
holding my kids during defensive period
and that's what Coach snow wanted so I
go to Indy or Tampa I put that in I go
to India I put that in well his mo on
Saturday was he had a yellow legal pad
of every play that wasn't exactly
perfect
on Wednesday Thursday Friday he wants to
run him over all right so he's you know
we're gonna have ten plays on offense
he's got 40 that he wants to run right
on Saturday right
so we compromise okay show me your top
plays we'll run him again then he's you
know I really need to run this at full
speed I don't need Marvin holding his
son walking through the wrap so I'm with
you on this can we just keep the kids
maybe in the locker room there no no I
hate family Saturdays when a lot of
Super Bowls will be okay yeah so that
was a battle where like once a month
fast forward when I start working for
NBC he's out in Denver now and they said
can you go out and do a story on Peyton
for the opening game so I go out there
Brandon Stokley who also played for a
stop area before I even get to the
locker room he said you will never
believe what Peyton did now he's got
twins he said he went to coach Fox that
we need to put in family that's great
coach dundies with us here why don't we
take a quick break you're gonna hang
around we got sports I want to talk more
about the X's and O's of the Super Bowl
we've talked about the Chiefs and the
difficulties they may have I'm
fascinated by this San Francisco offense
this old-school Miami Dolphins Bob
Griese he never throws the football that
we've seen over the past six quarters of
playoff football we'll do that
with coach Tony Dungy when pft life
continues right after this
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports